Elon recognized the power of cancel
culture and what they were doing I don't
think it's the sole component of why he
bought Twitter but you can see him
tweeting at Tim Cook apparently the
financial times reported that he was
calling CEO saying why are you dropping
us I think Elon knows the fear they have
of Twitter
I think anybody
I think most of you most people
listening understand this if you've got
Twitter followers and you have a problem
and you tweet about it that company
bends over backwards to help you I don't
like the system I think it's really wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold up hold on
let's hold the phone you know I've got a
lot of Twitter followers I can make
problems for people just by calling
someone no no no you can get whatever
you want wait I I want the I want what I
want okay so here's an example
um if you if you are boarding a plane
you can just oh yeah I had a terrible
experience oh yeah of course this is
horrible and they'll say We'll upgrade
you we're so sorry we'll give you
whatever you want wait you really
yes I can do this
I was sitting in the middle seat on my
flight here and let me tell you as soon
as I got off the plane I talked to the
manager from Tim cast and I certainly
were you on a middle seat I was in a
middle seat not like an animal well you
Sydney Watson
between two large larger people
according to Sid was that a quarter she
had receipts but the point I was making
just just try and stay on subject I
suppose is um
when you have a lot of followers and you
have a problem with a company you tweet
about it they will take care of you
because they know you can direct a lot
of bad reviews customer it's it's
negative advertising Twitter has created
a negative advertising space I I'm going
to Tweet at White Castle right now I
hate them they're really not good I'm
not joking it's inedible so let's see
what happens hold on hold on hold on you
misunderstand
I'm tweeting anyway I have three burgers
I don't want my castle with like cat
sliders yeah a little guy so like
imagine imagine this Elon Musk has 120
million followers done so when he says
Apple's pulling ads or Apple's
threatening to drop Twitter from the
platform and then he tweets directly at
Tim Cook Tim Cook is on blast his phone
starts
and he's going what's going on he's like
oh no elon's tweeting at me oh man he's
got 120 million followers what's
happened according to the financial
times is that when Elon calls the CEOs
they reinstate their ads but to a
minimum level okay to keep the money
flowing these ad networks are terrified
of whoever controls the communication
sphere and now Elon has it okay well it
looks like Elon has it but what whose
money is Elon using I told you not to
talk about on the air mobile Bankers
money that they can turn off your
account at any moment we've found with
Kanye's situation so let's talk about
who controls social media it's banking
I mean it's the money but you think Elon
isn't acting under his own volition I
think he is within the bounds that he's
given which is this is your US dollar
this is how you get by this is how you
get food you're you're not completely
off but there is agency among the
individual right Elon is very powerful
is the point I'm making he has Twitter
he can wield 120 million followers
that's why they're scared to go too hard
against them because you look at what
look at what's going on in China right
now even with the power and the Iron
Fist of the CCP people have have reached
their point so there are powerful
interests there are people and it's
self-interest too like these big
corporations they don't like that Elon
can push him around there are powerful
government interests they also don't
like the light of the spotlight on them
they want to stay like okay you know the
reason how it works is with like black
lives matter you don't want to be that
one corporation that didn't have that
black Square it's much easier to go with
the herd because then no one could pick
you off so when he calls someone or puts
them on blast all of a sudden there's no
good answer for you as a corporation
because now you're like I'm gonna offend
somebody and that's my nightmare
scenario their stock price will drop
yeah negative stock price yeah I mean I
don't know it did it by three percent oh
is that right I just saw a clip uh uh
okay screenshot yeah and and they know
that and they're like a three percent
drop is how how many billions of dollars
exactly like how many less iPhones are
we gonna sell and how much an ad revenue
is that gonna like if we spend 10
billion on ads how many or 10 million or
whatever yes Apple stock price is down
two percent well a lot of stocks are
down but uh seeing the war between Elon
and apple is pretty uh glorious it's
pretty amazing
it's it's spectacular to see because you
know Elon even said hey you know if this
gets too crazy if you guys ban us from
the Apple Store we're just gonna create
our own phone which you should do yeah I
think is awesome and I think the the
market is going to provide a solution to
a lot of the censorious a lot of the
insane algorithms and control systems
that is trying to of course suck out
Humanity from um you know existence well
do you think that the government should
strip 230 protections from these
companies I I think if if we have you
know organizations they're using these
kind of speech platforms using uh what
what is essentially our modern day town
halls and censoring people
editorializing people I think
um that right there is them taking
advantage of a situation and what should
be the larger what should be the larger
solution to that I I think you know they
do have a monopoly I think it's fair to
say that and and I think it needs to be
broken apart oh God oh my God okay now
before the show you both can go back to
Russia okay okay how do you how do you
deal with with Google how do you deal
with this problem because because like
state power obviously yeah because they
are they are an institution that is a
part of the state
right wait I'm not arguing there's
there's absolutely intertwine between
the them in the state you can't like
break up Twitter like that doesn't
really no I'm not saying breakup okay
I'm saying stop stop the government
they need to be broken up and not have
this unfair advantage that the
government gives them I hardly endorse
literally everything he just said okay
thank you I appreciate I know you got
scared there I did I don't I don't you
know trust me I don't want I don't want
more states to solve the problem of the
state but you're getting all Sherman no
no no no no no no no I'm not I'm not
getting there I'm just saying yes no
you're right the state empowers these
monopolies the state needs to stop
immediately section 230 is government
protection for big corporations to be
free from any liability for what they
publish recommend or otherwise while
they are also simultaneously free to
editorialize and promote whatever they
want that is insane imagine if we had a
law in this country that said you as a
newspaper can never be sued for
defamation but but that's ridiculous
this is one of the big Arguments for
anarchism meaning of separation of
government of Commerce and state for the
same reasons you have separation of
church and state because we saw with the
pharmaceutical companies which is this
deal on behalf of literally everyone in
America where you are going to make your
shot I don't even know what words I can
say on YouTube anymore and we really
needed to rush to Market understandably
under an emergency kind of unprecedented
situation but as a result of this
they're going to be no consequences for
you if things go bad yeah it couldn't
even be like you know what here's what's
going to happen if things go bad we as
the government are going to make some
kind of welfare and pay out for people
who had consequences for our wrongdoing
just like if there's certain on
situations like you're in war and you're
a soldier and you come back we're going
to take care of you they didn't even do
that they're just gonna be like you know
what no one's gonna be responsible and
that to me is government at its most
malevolent no liability at all which is
absolutely criminally insane especially
when there are clearly a lot of people
getting hurt by this they have no one to
go to who's going to be paying for their
medical bills who's going to be taking
care of them there's no ability to have
any kind of restitution at all which is
insane or even acknowledgment of
wrongdoing exactly
just here's the blank check yeah go for
it no there's no blank check there's
nothing there's Shut Up Get Away we told
you to do this we manipulated you to do
this we extorted you to do this we told
you you can't travel you can't live you
can't go see your grandma die unless you
do this you did this you got hurt who's
who's responsible no one you're
responsible for believing us that's
that's essentially what they're saying
at the end of the day here relatively
recently in history that they did that
too right whether they made the uh no
this has been going on since like Teddy
Rose I was gonna say vaccine immunity oh
no sorry I'm not like monopolies being
able to do what they want yeah in fact
protections are probably the new thing
vaccine immunity protection no no no no
no no no corporate protections corporate
corporations aren't uh what do you know
when the first Corporation was oh I I
bet this has been issued since like the
1890s I don't know what First
Corporation was it might be the 1890s
around then I'm not sure I don't think
so I think it's got to be earlier well
there is in a trading company I know
yeah exactly yeah that was like a
country man that was so right basically
but uh you think you had any rights
working for the East India Trading
Company they would issue script like
their own currency that you you'd have
to use on their territory to buy like
food from their stores and imagine what
would happen if they're like we want you
to go take this machete and go clear
Bush what if I get hurt they just laugh
like how could you even ask that
question do it or don't eat now because
you're replaceable right there's no
shortage of people from Ireland or
Eastern Europe who's you know we can
kind of fill your shoes it's only
recently in human history we started
saying like hey you know people should
be responsible if they're misleading if
they're causing problems or at the very
least if there is a if if like you
release a toy that has an issue that
needs to be recalled and you don't
people get like you you'll get sued
you're responsible something someone
hurts you the party that hurt you is
responsible is liable the government
steps in says no they're not liable but
also to add insults to injury they're
also acting like the pr agency of big
Pharma if we look at within the last few
years that the White House has
essentially become a a marketing an
advertisement arm of big Pharma and
other multinational corporations that
they agree with that enforce their
agenda that to me is another layer of
communism that we have to deal with
that's absolutely insane and needs to
stop immediately I feel so redundant
yeah he's saying all my
things what do I do here I need
I need status
when the Communists when the
right-wingers who want more government
here I need you here let's talk about
this thank you oh my God this is this is
please let's talk about this because
this is something that blew my mind
because it really drives me crazy how
conservatives use the word communist in
the same way that progressives use the
word racist just means something I don't
like I was on The Blaze on Election
night and Steve deese who's a Christian
conservative who I was very impressed by
he was very very bright uh he really
kind of understand how politics works
but his conclusion at the end was to
have Twitter be run as a public utility
by the government and I'm like you're
fighting communism by having these
organizations be run by the state under
socialists that's literally socialism
and then people take it even further by
saying you know I think I know what's
better for everyone I think they need
this in their life and that in the life
and we need the state to mandate this
and this and this and I'm like you're
sounding exactly like what you're
fighting against because they're
supposedly fighting again exactly the
leftists are making the same argument
saying I know it's better for you I know
what's wrong right for you and this is
why we need the state to intervene and
use their Monopoly of violence in order
to push my Wills onto you and I'm like
stop violating human rights when the
conservatives talk about we need to be
teaching Morality In Schools that's what
CRT is that is progressives teaching
their Morality In Schools let's we'll
have a conversation about this okay
um I think you can do something like put
Twitter under government control that's
not communism or socialism it may be
socialistic but it would also enshrine
theoretically First Amendment
protections on on this platform that's
become a weapon for one political
faction yeah but look at like NPR right
like NPR is uh heavily subsidized by the
state and they're so are they though
small minorly I believe it's very low
percent surprisingly then why are they
allowed to call themselves why were they
called Federal Express exactly it's
totally misleading and it should be
illegal well you can't call your like
there was a Ganesha calling yourself
Bank of something that like this was a
big issue because it was a really well
I've been told good for me I don't know
what if I you're right what if I call my
company official U.S government
Post Office business or so official U.S
government candy that was the name of my
company I mean that would have to be
illegal that makes no sense it would
make the kids
when you look it up and made this is
wrong it says NPR does not receive any
Direct Federal funding it receives small
competitive grants from cpb and federal
agencies like the Department of
Education and the Department of Commerce
and see so how are they funded if they
don't do they have advertising from
viewers like you oh I think it's mostly
money independent money well more power
I'm not I'm not actually kind of crazy
where they get that away from I don't
want to come out and say I think I I you
know I definitely agree that the problem
is government uh I think all Power
Systems tends tend towards corruption
over time yes and the problem is that
government programs Can't Fail there's
there there are like they're surrounded
by the Monopoly on violence like Luke
was saying and so they could never just
stop so perhaps Sunset Clauses in
anything is like maybe a constitutional
amendment all government programs and
laws will have a five-year Sunset must
be revoted upon by the people or
something like that the problem with
that is if you look at like a trademark
law right it used to be that that after
X amount of years a character becomes
public domain and Disney is just
lobbying Congress so Mickey Mouse and
Superman because they're made in the 30s
should have been public domain that I
know how many years ago meaning anyone
can make a Superman movie anyone can
make a Mickey Mouse movie and they just
keep pushing the bucket down the road
because there's such an asymmetry Disney
has a huge interest in this the rest of
us have a little power or interest in
this it's it's the Symmetry is never
going to be in the favor of the freedom
I think agreed in regards to how you
deal with a monopolistic social media
Network I kind of agree I don't want the
government controlling who gets to say
what on the network because that's just
another kind of Monopoly if the
government was to be like no we're in a
monopoly it's just popular like it it's
very difficult to have several search
engines because one is effectively going
to be much more optional than the others
yeah and because it's better it's become
maybe you're right maybe the word
monopoly is not the right word but I
feel like Google has a monopoly on
internet search they maybe not because
Brave is there DuckDuckGo exists but
like if those other things had a
competitive Advantage for some way
because Google beat Yahoo I'm old enough
to know Yahoo as the search engine there
was Alta Vista and there was web crawler
and there's Ask Jeeves I don't know if
those still exist but the point is
Google won because their search results
were more useful so I don't know how you
would even beat Google in that regard
well I don't think you can
from myself there was the film The
creepy line which they put which is what
they really should be going after is how
Google operates and as an example if I
am searching for let's suppose the guy
Robert uh I forget Robert Levine maybe
his name was uh the professor let's
suppose I'm searching for Hillary
Clinton right and Google makes it so the
top 10 search results are articles that
are positive toward Hillary Clinton and
if I search for Donald Trump Google
makes it to the top 10 articles are
critical of Donald Trump that is going
to skew the electorate one way or
another and all of us would be oblivious
to see that Google has their their thumb
on the scale so that is the kind of
thing where the government can be
investigating and being like all right
uh something here is not adding up
because you're acting as a political
agency and in that case there's all
sorts of things that go with it all I
come to is to I mean the audience served
this before probably but free the
software code yes yes Amen brother I
agree with Ian on that in terms of so we
know the algorithms that are managed yes
yes but not the property line of it
right correct you know I would bring in
experts to talk about what really needs
to be freed I don't think it's every
ounce of lettering in every code base
and I should have him on the guy who he
got he like he got kicked off of Gmail
because of this like he basically did
the work and he's like we like for
example another thing he found is like
Facebook they would if you liked Hillary
they would hit you with you should go
out and vote if you like Trump uh Robert
Epstein yeah I think that's the name yes
correct hell yeah
no relationship you can't search for him
anymore yes what a surprise psychologist
he was basically saying that the the
search algorithm was flip was flipping
votes yeah and the way he described it
not only does it make perfect sense
you'd have no way of knowing yep then
there was many there was even many
scientific studies detailing how big
Tech social media companies can swing
elections and help candidates win when
they had no chance of winning during the
uh there were Twitter hearings in
Congress
Republican brought up that when you were
in DC
and you sign up for Twitter Twitter
recommends Democrats and only Democrats
wow
he was like why is it
this is what you get well let's play
Devil's Advocate it could be that the
DC's overwhelming Democrat right so if
the odds are if you're in DC you want to
follow Democrat and that and that's you
know when I did this phone call with
this guy that's basically he was saying
he's like don't you want us to be able
to show you what you want
and I'm like I want to be shown what I
choose to watch yeah you know I like
this is the way they think we know what
you want more than you do you know
sometimes I get these Instagram ads and
I end up buying a UFO and then buying a
second UFO
um because it was a cool ad wait where's
the second one in Adam craigler's house
it's gone oh yeah unfortunate well this
is the second one how much are those
it's like 200 bucks okay this is cool I
saw it on Instagram and I'm like oh I
want to get that and so they kind of
figured it out you know I want something
right but when it comes to political
content it doesn't work the same way
right it becomes extremely nightmarish
when you start this this is what I was
explaining to Dorsey and vajayagade that
if they keep doing what they're doing
there's going to be uh I don't think I
said the word Civil War back then but
maybe maybe if you go watch the episode
because what I was trying to get to is
you're basically you're forcing everyone
into into yep yep you are creating 100
polarization on purpose and they were
like whatever they didn't care but I
think all in their def their defense of
using that term very Loosely the thing
is with social media and you have these
conversations it works kind of
evolutionarily in that anyone's
philosophy is going to be driven to its
logical conclusion because you run
enough iterations that any kind of
contradictions are kind of going to go
away and you're going to go toward
towards the extreme or The Logical
conclusion of whatever their premises
are so that is why kind of in many ways
this moderate middle is is Vanishing
because being in the middle is not
really a coherent position it's just
kind of a reaction to these two other
polls yeah the middle can be like
extreme right left really fast so fast
that it looks like it's in the middle so
it's still there's still a balance in
the extremes if you can handle it
hopefully most people can I mean you
kind of have to when you're on social
media because it's so extreme when you
log on to it's so extreme everything is
so extreme it's like not everything it's
like Mountain Dew they got me talking
extreme I'm curious some people have
suggested that Elon musk's moves are
actually against the right because uh
there's this idea I've talked about you
have two kids one is covered in filth
and dirt and mud and the other looks
beautiful and pristine with a nice
little suit and tie on let's call them
Ian and Luke Ian and Luke and so
hear me
when you approach this woman and you see
one child smeared with ice cream all
over his face and I'll start off that
was my chance
when you see a kid all messy covered in
ice cream and one kid who's looking very
clean you assume man that kid must be
unruly and crazy that kid must be
responsible in reality the mom just
doesn't give the clean the kid who's
clean any treats or or or reprieve and
is mean to him
the kid was messy gets whatever he wants
they're both actually bad kids what
happens on Twitter is they start
removing people on the right okay this
is bad you're gone bad you're gone and
all that's left are moderate and
moderate conservatives to Center you
know like center right to Modern
conservative voices and on the left they
say you can do whatever you want so you
end up with antifa violence extremist
posts
so so it's skews and ends up making the
left look insane
Elon comes in and I'm not saying he's
doing this on purpose maybe he's just
genuinely like free speech some people
are saying allowing everybody back on
who's Crazy is going to actually end up
making the right look bad because it's
going to bring back the worst possible
voices no I don't think he hasn't first
of all he hasn't brought back Carpe
dongtum who's like the number one on my
list because making memes for Trump uh
there's no reason for him to be banned
it's completely crazy so Elon please
bring back carpet donkey brought back
well he's bringing back everyone he's
bringing back tens of thousands users
very soon so is he bringing back
everyone is he bringing up Milo
everything Chuck Johnson he he did a
poll saying a blanket amnesty for anyone
that didn't spam or or clearly violate
the bigger rules yeah but everyone's
going to be back there's that asterisk
62 000 people fine my point is we don't
know that that's going to include the
people who were like where Twitter had
previously regarded as the worst the
worst I agree I agree
um like Jones he's out there said he
wouldn't bring him back does this mean
he will that was interesting they asked
someone asked Elon I think it was uh
Viva Frey maybe Viva fry Fray David how
do you say your last name for right uh
if he would bring back Alex and he was
like no no I have no respect for people
that would I'm paraphrasing what elon's
response was in text that uh he values
children and anyone that would demean
and use children for political gain or
power he's totally disgusting that's all
of Washington and that's an example of
like you're gonna let one guy run your
social media I responded to that do you
know what Obama did in the Middle East
and how many weddings and children he
bombed but it's an example of like you
let one guy run a network he has total
emotional control of who gets to play
what's that emotional I think he's
making a coherent if incorrect in your
opinion perspective yeah but it I mean
he's not allowed I think he paid the
price for saying those things in public
and Free Speech I mean he's done his you
know he's I hate can we talk about this
I really really hate that term free
speech I don't ever use it uh because it
means so many different things to
different people yeah like some people
think oh if you're blocking me you're
blocking my free speech it's like if I'm
not letting you in the house no there's
a lot of conservatives to say that too
oh you're all yeah I thought you're for
free speech and now you blocked me off
your page because I'm I'm an idiot who's
babbling Magista did you tell them that
freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
from consequences well I can't reply
them once they're blocked oh yeah that's
the argument because is it free speech
to go on Twitter and say all these
racist stuff and then you get banned
it's still elon's free speech to block
whoever he wants but then you're like
well is it a public company is it a
private company now we're in New
Territory free speech is a principle
it's like an ethic it's a it's a
position that we hold culturally at
least we did for a long time until you
know culture started shifting I guess
everybody opposes Free Speech when they
can knock them from power as opposed to
varying degrees I remember being a small
kid being like yeah it's a free country
I could say what I want now now we don't
have that on Twitter if you are allowed
to go on and say your opinions as
repugnant as they may be that is free
speech if Elon Musk says some opinions
are not allowed he does not believe in
free speech Free Speech there there are
reasonable limits I think is fair I
don't think doxing should be allowed and
that is First Amendment protected speech
so you know even I am not an absolutist
here let's talk about doxing if
someone's uh like contact information is
public right like under in a phone book
whatever it is and you republish that do
you consider that to be doxing
that's tough right that's a tough one
right is it is it doxing if someone just
Google someone you could find their I
don't think that actually qualifies but
I don't like it I I think that's really
kind of egregious and I think you guys
would probably agree
I think it is egregious yeah right the
government also sells your addresses
many times through the DMV through
private corporations is that right later
you could buy yeah people's their
services online where you could where
people go and buy government Registries
and then have people's addresses where
people could buy it online and find out
where they live it's like if I send your
address to one person is that doxing if
I send it to 10 now is that if it's a
hundred like at what point does it
become a docs I think it becomes a box
when you're sending it to Strangers Like
Pub so if it's public does it or private
leads to strangers to straight people I
don't know yeah I think or with the
intent certainly it kind of plays into
here like this is something it's not
like hey wish Ian a happy birthday send
them a card to his address
it's a fine line we got to respect
people's privacy but also at the same
time we got to respect people's speech
where do you draw the line yeah because
I'm allowed to say what your address is
I'm allowed
in public under the first amendment
doxing is is protected you can hold up a
big sign with someone's edges and walk
around with it it's actually also really
kind of crazy I'm reading biography
autobiography of this woman Mabel Dodge
Luhan who had these salons in her house
in the early 20th century where
modernism started and the articles in
the New York Times would be like Mrs
Mabel Dodge comma of five East 23rd
Street New York and it would just have
her address there it's like this seems
like it's a problem yeah well I guess
culture is the is is the biggest issue
in my opinion when it comes to
everything most of the political stuff
we're dealing with is cultural when you
have a culture that is cohesive and
agrees on morals and ethics like you can
leave your door open at night
you don't have to worry as much about
crime but when you have a a society a
country where everyone's just like
you're not a part of my community I
don't know you I don't care now you got
to lock your doors it seems like when
you have small localities there tends to
be a homogenization of culture because
there's only 70 of us you know we all
know where 7th Street is but as soon as
you introduce a hundred thousand or 10
million unknowns to the culture you're
in a state of like I can't leave my I
can't leave my address online anymore
because we used to have the Yellow Pages
yeah like there used to be books of
everyone this used to be the big appeal
of cities that if you're from some small
town where everyone knew your business
you could go somewhere and get lost and
vanish and that it's not just a thing
for criminals it could be things like
you know I want to ReDiscover myself I
want to have create a new identity for
myself I want to get away from this kind
of upbringing I had so this was back in
the day of benefit of cities but thanks
to the internet that's kind of gone away
I don't need to go live approximately to
people who share my world people I could
just find it through social media so on
and so forth and given how just
deleteriously cities have been
collapsing in the last 10 years in terms
of just basic safety and and public
services is it's just the the question
on the table I think for many of us is
are cities an outdated mode of of
organization or or our governments
because cities yes way way more
government than a lot of other places
that have a lot less government you guys
are menarchists
that's the most insulting thing they
could ever tell me to my face
I know worse than that like you said you
said that social media needs a little
bit there's a fight those are fighting
earlier I think you were saying about
Twitter that my goodness maybe you are
you I have a machete here you're down to
to break up monopolies with government
is that what you're like you said
earlier that you want the government to
be involved
so much do you see what I have to deal
with every day you told me you're a
menarchists I've never had to my face
here like nine years ago Anarchist maybe
but no zero government because then the
corporations just take control the
corporation oh my God every day yeah
please read this okay
okay
one sentence if you have a job that's
basically a government but think about
corporations can become a government if
they're unchecked the only entity or
institution anywhere for any reason at
any point that could make a road is the
government
a socialized government can protect free
roads for people better than a
corporation in my opinion that but
that's your opinion is you sound like
Jason Whitlock your opinion's based on
nothing I love Jason's based on nothing
we can look very quickly to find out
private roads versus public roads and
how safe they are how often they break
down potholes things like this and it's
not even equ cost well hold on you know
when when the government builds the road
there's a simple solution to the
potholes KFC comes in and fills them and
then it was Domino's who did that oh
okay yes what you were saying I think
the evidence would be that corporations
are authoritarian by Nature you have one
person in control that decides who stays
who goes and if they control a busy
roadway well I'm triggered you do this I
can't handle it I deal with this every
day your turn so so um a busy roadway
for instance if of course if Google
owned you know I-76 I'd rather talk to
Kanye
but most people might might agree with
you you have an opportunity he's going
to storm out yeah so what do you do if
we got a both storm up if alphabet or
Microsoft owned like I-77 North and then
you and then like tomorrow we don't want
any black people on that road and you're
like where's our government to protect
us from The Psychotic Corporation oh
okay so let's walk through this uh
thought experiment and I've never used
the word thought more Loosely what do
you think would happen to alphabet if
they publicly said we are going to have
a part of our company that is forbidden
for use by black people forgetting
lawsuits and discrimination law
literally what do you think would happen
to that company Auntie if it would show
up with crowbars the only thing that
happened the stock price
overnight um well let's think about this
who controls the stock market who what
if they what if people tried to storm
the headquarters antifa overnight and
they have armed guards outside that
killed them all and where's the
government to stop that from happening
okay I I'm talking about this peacefully
forget antifa if a company declares we
are not going to have part of our
organization accessible to black people
do you think there will be no extreme
immediate consequences for that company
I would hope that there were but I think
that when Vanderbilt shut off the
railroads to New York there was
obviously there comes times where he had
so much control system
a general a general um boycott isn't
enough because it controls so much
aspects of society already I I think
this is you don't even need a boycott
because anyone who's a publicly traded
company is there at the behest of the
stock owners and the board so if I am
whoever's running alphabet now I don't
even know his name and say first of all
I don't even know how to say I don't
even know how they're going to get this
so plan through but if someone just if
let's Elon if Elon Musk tomorrow says
all right here's the new rule on Twitter
no one who's black can be on Twitter and
that even includes uh well uh what's his
name
um Sean whatever
Sean King Sean King even sean King
you're not welcome your talcum X thank
you he's not allowed on Twitter the
number of audience would implode the
number of news articles to be through
the roof and the stock price would be
nothing and all that money that he's
owed I don't know how that would work
but those Banks would call him that debt
yeah so you might be right because of
the because of the emotional charge
about racism you're right there could be
reactions now let's take something more
Insidious BlackRock wants to buy
Farmland in the United States what if
they buy it all where's our government
protection do you under okay do you
understand how what determines price
um ideally no not ideally supply and
demand but I mean it's so as literally
so it's who if they're colluding they
can uh the government decides you can't
stop you can't set your prices you know
we have protection so that the
corporations aren't deciding what the
price is well wait so if I am buying
let's suppose just eggs right the more
eggs I buy the higher the price of eggs
becomes right and then it becomes
asymptotic right in a in like a
mechanical system that's supposed to
happen real estate is a great example of
this like Austin and New York as more
and more people are trying to buy real
estate the prices are extremely quickly
increasing right yeah we know this so
Taylor Swift tickets yeah right I don't
know how much Farmland there is in
America it's a lot but at a certain
point the costs are going to increase
very very high and BlackRock if they're
not earning a return on their I'm not
I'm not a fan of BlackRock by the way
I'm not saying this is something we
should be like applauding I'm just
saying there are mechanisms already in
place that the idea that BlackRock can
buy America I don't even know how much
the cost of America would be it just
would be and I want to point out too
your concerns about BlackRock are based
on the fact that they get free money
from the government yeah exactly
it's not the government I mean it's the
bank so we want more government to deal
with the problem of government no the
government it's not the government it's
the Federal Reserve and the bank for
international settlements that are
supplying the funds to Blackrock it's
not the American government we are in
favor of treating the members of the
Federal Reserve as war criminals I think
I can speak for Luke in this is that
fair to say yes okay
private company but no no more criminals
Federal Reserve is a private company are
you so I I I I am I am I speaking I'm
not saying they're not war criminals I'm
just saying it's a private company
they're not a private company at all and
they should be treated like war
criminals are you suggesting they're a
government agency I'm not suggesting it
I'm saying it no the Federal Reserve is
a private it's a quasi-price
organization but it was invented by JD
Rockefeller John Rockefeller Paul
Warburg in 1913. this is the nightmare
scenario of when you have this kind of
corporate government intertwining where
you have this almost like a Frankenstein
creature that's half one foot half the
other and no accountability no liability
and that is exactly what anarchists like
me and Luke and anarchists of all colors
of the Black Flag are opposed to because
this is what Marx referred to as
capitalism fascism now I agree that
fascism is the other end of the spectrum
whereas corporatism is equally as
dangerous corporatism is fascism it's
just fascism with a better brand name
fascism is going to bring government
into it corporatism could be like
John Rockefeller owns every road and now
if John Rockefeller doesn't like you he
can't drive okay that's bad how is he
gonna afford do you know how much every
road would cost like even Elon Musk with
45 billion dollars that can buy you
maybe the roads in like one city yeah
but they know the bankers that print the
money and they can but again that's the
federal that's the Federal Reserve it's
not American government that's different
it's a private company the American
Reserve has given their power to it's
total Co-op of our government yes that
is corporatism they're using government
in to do this the government is the Fall
Guy the American Republic is legit
what is their America a republic is the
government it's supposed to smash up
Monopoly supposed to is a blue pill word
supposed to doesn't exist we have you
know Anti-Trust laws to break up like
Rockefeller standard oil at the end
we have antitrust laws so monopolies
will play ball by whoever's in power
even Teddy Roosevelt and Wilson who were
the first two Progressive presidents
both explicitly said there are good
trusts and bad trusts meaning the
monopolies that do what we want and
Napoli's that don't do what they want
this is exactly a mechanism just like
Facebook and Google other things Biden
will call you up because he's got these
antitrust laws behind him or whatever
other laws at his dispose and be like
you know what we'd really like it if you
were censoring this misinformation it's
dangerous to our democracy and they're
like oh of course we're doing it
privately but it's not privately because
it's a complete collusion between the
state and the free market ostensibly
free market do you think that if if
Government were totally removed and it
was just Market that it would work out
that everybody would be happier and and
wealth healthier and not everyone
certainly the politicians are they're
gonna it's gonna be really hard for them
when consequences will never be the same
I feel like Corporation tendency to
profit over human goodness is like you
can only process even like slaves you
can only slavery is not profitable it's
expensive number one and besides it's
immoral would you be buying candy bars
from a company that's built on slave
labor
uh well the sneakers I got this thing
it's probably built in a Chinese lab
yeah I think I think everything in here
might be like and I shouldn't say
everything but a lot of it's this table
is actually American made locally the
cameras are foreign made by people in
horrible conditions well that's a
problem it is I agree that's why we make
governments to stop that in my opinion
the benevolence of government is that it
can protect us but in fact over the past
couple of decades the government has
been colluding with foreign corporations
to sell all of our jobs overseas to
benefit China
it's what Nixon did with the with
Rockefeller and Henry Kissinger it was
an open policy the open China policy
that they implemented so you got to
understand like Ian at the end of the
day all roads lead to of course the
government abusing its power because
they don't need to provide a service
based on any kind of reputation or any
kind of consequences thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time